sea sand and semi-automatic rifles
it's the new reality for Mexico's top
Beach destination the Caribbean Resort
of Cancun a hot spot for spring breaking
Americans and European holiday makers
but one in which Marines now guard the
beaches
they're here for a reason in Cancun over
recent years crime and violence have
been on the rise
four people killed near the beach just
before Easter the latest Flashpoint
holiday makers Sophie and Kirsty are
soaking up the Rays as the security
forces pass
you've just seen all of the the Marines
and the police come patrolling down the
beach
what were you thinking yeah but pretty
strange site
I thought there was going to be an
altercation or there was something here
or a threat or something the reason that
or maybe preventative measures are
definitely cautious and we were
definitely like we were looking around
at other people's reactions and seeing
if anybody else is reacting and I'm sure
if other people were scared then we'd
probably leave but when you look around
it seems pretty normal
the presence of troops here has become
normal a battalion of the National Guard
is now stationed on this Coast
authorities know they have to protect
the tourist trade at all costs you'd
think that images like this one would
have put people off but tourists keep
arriving in Cancun despite a real surge
in violence in this town over the last
few years
meanwhile those living here are facing
daily battles if I'm opening a new
business in Cancun what's the
probability that I'm going to be
extorted well I think it's going to be
like
50 50. yeah yeah I think uh the other
day in the meeting they asked like how
many of you have to suffer any type of
extortion 85 of the business
he should know he's already had a
restaurant destroyed by gangsters
Cancun's become a juicy prize for the
biggest cartels in the country they
demand that business owners allow them
to sell drugs on their premises or
simply give them protection money
from those Hawking inflatables on the
beach to the popular bars on the Strip
nobody's too big or too small to get out
of paying
the police say they're getting to grips
with things
we visit restaurants and we visit
businesses so that people feel that the
police are close to them and they can
come to us when there is an extortion
call then we can follow up in the
streets while the state attorney's
office goes after the criminal
organizations
but only one person in Cancun has been
tried and convicted for extortion and
they're appealing
and they're already closed restaurants
shops that's an as yet incipient Trend
that this money maker for the Mexican
economy once stopped before the tourists
decide to go elsewhere
John Holman Al Jazeera Cancun